Joell is working on a school report in a
word processor processor she wants to
place a figure which is thirteen point
zero nine centimeters wide so that it
appears centered on the page the width
of the page is twenty-one point five
nine centimeters how much margin should
she leave on the left so that the figure
is centered so let's visualize what's
going on we have a page that's
twenty-one point five nine centimeters
wide so this distance right over here is
so this right over here that is our page
let me draw the actual page we'd rather
than white since paper tends to be white
so this is her page our page is
twenty-one point five nine centimeters
wide it's just like that's a little
unusual dimension for a piece of paper
but we'll go with it and then she wants
to place a figure that is thirteen point
zero nine centimeters wide in the center
of the page so the figure the figure
I'll do in magenta the field like that's
not magenta the figure is thirteen point
zero nine centimeters so let's say that
this is the figure right over here so
this is the figure that she wants to
place in the middle of the page so this
is thirteen point zero nine centimeters
zero nine centimeters so the question is
how much margin should she leave on the
left so that the figure is centered so
they're really asking what how much what
should this distance what should this
distance be here so that the figure is
centered and the key thing is if the
figure is centered this distance is
going to be the same as this distance so
that the figure is right in the middle
whatever this is is going to be the same
as this so one way we could think about
it we could say ok let's take thirteen
point zero nine centimeters from
twenty-one point five nine centimeters
and if we do that then we'll be left
over what will well know how much
leftover space this Plus this combined
is and then we just want to split that
space in half we want half of it to go
on the right side and we want half of it
to go on the left side so let's see how
much this left margin and
right margin combined need to be and
that's just 21 point five nine that's
just going to be twenty-one point five
nine centimeters - - thirteen point zero
nine centimeters and this we get to
let's see this is this is 8.50
centimeters which is the combined
margins not just the left or not just
the right this is the left plus the
right margin is 8.50 centimeters this is
this distance Plus this distance now if
we want to figure out what the left
margin should be if we want to Center it
well we just want to split this evenly
between the left and the right margin so
we just want to divide this by two so if
you divide eighteen point five oh by 2
or multiply it by 1/2 I guess that might
be a little bit more obvious either way
so if we multiply this by 1/2 you are
left with half of 8.50 is 4.25
centimeters so if we want it centered
this is going to be four point two two
five centimeters and of course this is
going to be four point two five
centimeters as well and you see when you
add four point two five to four point
two five you get eight point five
centimeters and then you add that to
thirteen point zero nine you get the
entire width of the piece of paper so
how much margin should she leave on the
left four point two five centimeters